[Applaudissements]
tout une fête pour une île jutra il dit
au revoir à l'équipe de pédiatrie qui le
suit depuis des aides publiques l'école
le docteur patel connaît une île depuis
sa greffe cardiaque en 2002 au
débouchage fréquente une fois par
semaine au moins
mais maintenant quelques fois par année
on est tellement fier de miel elle a eu
des défis certaine pour ce qui est des
infections faut faire attention mais à
part ce petit garçon normal qu'ils
s'amusent bien que joue bien qui se
charge bien qu'ils n'aiment pas la
vaisselle hymne il aura 18 ans la
semaine prochaine
chanceux j'en suis moins stressé power
l'amener là il quitte donc l'hôpital
pour enfants qui lui a sauvé la vie
alors qu'il avait deux ans un virus
s'attaquer à son coeur et les médecins
ont utilisé pour la première fois en
amérique un coeur mécanique pour un tout
petit enfant le coeur de berlin est un
coeur mécanique assez petit et qui
gardera et milan vit 109 jours jusqu'à
la grève vous pouvez le voir en attente
de la transplantation cardiaque les
grands alors dans tout ça 5000 parce que
c'est lui qui est le champion et un
courage incroyable
l'enfant de trois ans célèbre
aujourd'hui le premier anniversaire de
sa greffe cardiaque
i mean jutra revient de loin on le
considère comme un petit miraculé comme
adultes émile liera à l'hôpital victoria
du centre universitaire de santé mcgill
bonjour sa nouvelle cardiologue le
connaît déjà ce qui est fascinant quand
même de voir surtout dans un coffre mais
miné il y avait juste deux ans que le
coeur a grandi avec lui au québec on
pratique une quarantaine de greffe
cardiaque par année autour de 4 chez les
enfants pour eux on utilise encore
parfois le coeur de berlin
même s'il existe une nouvelle génération
d' assistance mécanique pour les adultes
on a gagné à la loterie lorsque le coeur
de berlin ville d'auray mais lorsqu'on
entend des histoires où d'autres enfin
en profite on dit on est tellement on a
fait le bon choix puis on a d'autres
gens du club
l'histoire très suivis des 1000 avait
aussi contribué à promouvoir le
consentement au don d'organes une
coépouse et par toute la famille jutra
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal